Soy bien conocido por el vuelo a propulsión humana,
pero eso fue sólo una de las cosas que me hicieron empezar
en el tipo de cosas en las que trabajo ahora.
Cuando era joven, estaba muy interesado en el aeromodelismo,
ornitópteros, autogiros, helicópteros, deslizadores, aviones autopropulsados,
modelos de interior, modelos de exterior -- todo,
me parecía que era muy divertido,
y me preguntaba por qué la mayoría de la gente no compartía mi entusiasmo por ellos.
Y después, me entrené para piloto de la marina y, tras la universidad,
me metí en vuelos sin motor, vuelos propulsados,
y consideraba el vuelo sin motor como un tipo de afición y diversión,
pero debatiendo con algunos grandes profesores
nos convencieron a mí y a todos los demás en la materia,
de que era una buena forma de meterse en ciencia realmente seria.
Mientras ocurría todo esto, yo estaba en el campo de la modificación del clima,
aunque me estaba sacando un Doctorado en ingeniería aeronáutica.
La rama de modificación del clima estaba empezando,
y como un estudiante graduado,
podía aparecer por las distintas charlas que se estaban llevando a cabo,
a lo largo de un viaje a la costa Este haciendo auto-stop (aventón)
etc., y todo el mundo hablaba conmigo,
pero todos los profesionales en la materia se odiaban unos a otros,
y no se comunicaban. Como resultado,
obtuve un conocimiento único en la materia,
y fundé una compañía, que hizo más investigación
en modificación del clima que cualquier otra,
y hay un montón más de cosas en las que simplemente no me puedo meter.
Pero entonces, en 1971 fundé AeroVironment, sin empleados --
después con uno o dos, tres,
e intentando como podía conseguir proyectos interesantes.
Estaba AirDynanisis*,
quienes, como yo, no quería trabajar para compañías aeroespaciales
en algunos grandes proyectos a largo plazo,
y por eso hicimos nuestros pequeños proyectos, y la compañía creció lentamente.
Lo interesante fue que, en 1976,
me interesé repentinamente por el avión de propulsión humana
porque había hecho un préstamo de 100.000 dólares a un amigo
o avalaba el dinero al banco.
Él los necesitaba -- necesitaba el dinero para crear una compañía.
La compañía no triunfó, y no pudo devolver el dinero,
y yo era el aval del préstamo. De modo que tenía una deuda de 100.000 dólares,
y me di cuenta de que el premio Kramer al vuelo por propulsión humana,
que entonces ya estaba por ahí desde hace
17 años en aquella época, era de 50.000 libras,
que, con la tasa de cambio, era justamente alrededor de los 100.000 dólares.
Así, de repente, estaba interesado en el vuelo por propulsión humana,
(Risas)
y no -- el modo en que lo enfoqué, al principio,
pensando en formas de hacer los aviones,
era exactamente como lo habían estado haciendo en Inglaterra, sin éxito,
y me rendí. Pensé, bah, no hay ninguna forma simple y sencilla,
pero entonces me fui de vacaciones, y estaba estudiando el vuelo de los pájaros,
únicamente por diversión,
y podía ver un pájaro volando en círculos,
y medir el tiempo, estimar el ángulo de alabeo
e inmediatamente, calcular su velocidad,
y el radio de giro, etc.,
cosa que podía hacer en el coche mientras conducía en el viaje de vacaciones,
(Risas)
con mis tres hijos, jóvenes, ayudándome,
pero riéndose de todo el asunto bastante.
El... -- pero aquello empezó pensando acerca de cómo los pájaros daban vueltas,
y después cómo los aviones podrían -- cómo las ala delta podrían volar,
y después otros aviones,
y la idea del avión tipo "Gossamer Condor" surgió rápidamente,
era tan lógico, que cualquiera debería haber pensado en ello en primer lugar,
pero nadie lo hizo, y era simplemente mantener el peso bajo.
sólo pesaba 70 libras, pero permitiendo aumentar el tamaño, como un ala delta
pero con tres veces la envergadura, tres veces el cable,
bajas a un tercio de la velocidad, un tercio de la potencia,
y un buen ciclista puede proporcionar esa potencia, y funcionó,
y ganamos el premio un año después.
No... -- un montón de pruebas, un montón de experimentos, un montón de cosas que no funcionaban,
y otras que sí funcionaron, y el avión continuó mejorando y mejorando.
Conseguimos un buen piloto, Brian Allen, para pilotarlo,
y finalmente lo logramos, pero desafortunadamente,
alrededor de 65.000 dólares fueron gastados en el proyecto.
(Risas)
Y sólo quedaron cerca de 30.000 dólares para ayudar a cancelar la deuda.
Pero afortunadamente, Henry Kramer, quien había ofrecido el premio --
se trataba de un vuelo de una milla, estableció un nuevo premio,
por atravesar volando el Canal de La Mancha, 21 millas,
y pensó que le llevaría otros 18 años a alguien lograrlo.
Nos dimos cuenta de que, si limpiábamos nuestro "Gossamer Condor" un poco,
la potencia para volar bajaría un poco,
y si bajas un poco la potencia necesaria para volar,
el piloto puede volar durante mucho más tiempo.
Y Brian Allen fue capaz, en un milagroso vuelo,
de hacer al "Gossamer Condor" cruzar el Canal de La Mancha,
y ganamos el premio de 200.000 -- 100.000 libras, 200.000 dólares gracias a eso,
y cuando todos los gastos fueron pagados, la deuda había sido cancelada, y todo marchaba bien.
Resultó que darle los aviones al museo
valía más que la deuda,
así que durante cinco años, seis años, sólo tenía que pagar un tercio de los impuestos sobre facturación.
Así que había buenas razones económicas para el proyecto, pero --
(Risas)
Ese no era -- bueno, el proyecto fue realizado únicamente por razones económicas,
y no hemos estado involucrados en ningún vuelo por propulsión humana desde entonces
(Risas)
porque los premios ya se han acabado,
pero estoy seguro de que eso me hizo empezar a pensar sobre varias cosas,
e inmediatamente, empezamos a fabricar un avión propulsado por energía solar
porque sentimos que la energía solar iba a ser muy importante
para el país y el mundo,
no queríamos que la baja financiación del gobierno bajase,
que es lo que el gobierno intentaba hacer,
y pensamos que un avión propulsado por energía solar no tendría mucho sentido,
pero podía hacerse, y obtendría mucha publicidad para la energía solar
y quizás ayudar al desarrollo de este campo.
Y ese proyecto continuó, triunfó,
y entonces empezamos con otros proyectos en aviación
y artefactos mecánicos y dispositivos de tierra.
Pero mientras esto ocurría,
en 1982, recibí un premio de la Fundación Lindbergh --
su premio anual --
y tuve que preparar un informe al respecto,
que recogió todos mis variados pensamientos,
y variados intereses a lo largo de los años.
Esta fue mi oportunidad para concentrarme en lo que, realmente, buscaba,
y era importante. Y para mi sorpresa,
me di cuenta de la importancia de los problemas ambientales,
a los que Charles Lindbergh dedicó el último tercio de su vida,
y preparar ese informe me hizo mucho bien.
Pensé que si fuese un viajero espacial,
y volviese a visitar la tierra cada 5.000 años,
tras unos cientos de visitas, vería lo mismo cada vez,
las pequeñas diferencias en la Tierra.
Pero esta última vez, simplemente pasando por aquí, justo ahora,
repentinamente, habría enormes cambios en el entorno,
en la concentración de la población,
y sería simplemente increíble, la cantidad de -- todos los cambios sufridos.
Quería -- bueno, uno de los mayores cambios es, hace 200 años,
empezamos a usar carbón del subsuelo, que produce mucha polución,
y hace 100 años, empezamos a obtener gasolina del subsuelo,
con un montón de polución y consumo de gasolina -- o producción,
alcanzará su límite en alrededor de diez años, y entonces bajará,
y nos preguntamos qué pasará con el transporte.
Quiero enseñaros la diapositiva --
esta diapositiva, creo, es la más importante que veréis nunca, porque
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
muestra la naturaleza contra los humanos, y va desde 1850 al 2050,
y por ello, el año 2000, lo veis allí,
y este es el peso de todos los vertebrados aéreos y terrestres.
Humanos y ratas almizcleras, y jirafas, y pájaros, etc. son --
la línea roja sube, esa es la porción de los humanos, y ganado, y mascotas.
La línea verde baja, esa es la porción de la naturaleza salvaje.
Humanos, ganado y mascotas suponen, ahora, el 98% del total de la masa mundial
de vertebrados en tierra y aire,
y no sabemos qué deparará el futuro
pero no va a bajar el porcentaje.
Hace 10.000 años, los humanos, ganado y mascotas
no suponían ni la décima parte de un 1%
y ni siquiera habría sido visible esa curva,
ahora es el 98%, y es -- Yo creo, que muestra la dominación de los humanos en la Tierra.
Doy una charla a algunos estudiantes de instituto brillantes cada verano,
y les pregunto, después de que ellos me hayan hecho preguntas,
y les he dado una charla y esas cosas. Entonces les hago preguntas.
¿Cuál es la población de la Tierra?
¿Cuál será la población de la tierra
cuando tengáis la edad de vuestros padres?
Cosa que yo nunca me habría- en realidad -- ellos nunca habían pensado en ello, en realidad
pero, ahora, piensan sobre ello.
Y entonces, ¿Qué población de la Tierra mantendría un equilibrio
que fuese sostenible, y mantenerse para el 2050, 2100, 2150?
Entonces forman pequeños grupos, discutiendo con los demás,
y cuando me voy, dos horas después
la mayor parte de ellos hablan de dos mil millones de personas,
y no tienen ni idea de cómo bajar la población a dos mil millones,
ni la tengo yo, pero creo que están en lo cierto y éste es un problema serio.
Rachel Carson estaba pensando en esto, y publicó Silent Spring, hace ya tiempo.
El Manifiesto Solar de Hermann Scheer, de Alemania,
dice que toda la energía de la Tierra puede ser obtenida, en cualquier país,
de la energía solar, e hidráulica, etc.
no necesitas excavar en busca de productos químicos,
y podemos hacer las cosas de manera más eficiente.
Vamos a ver la siguiente diapositiva.
Esto es el resumen, "A lo largo de miles de millones de años,
sobre una esfera única, la casualidad va pintado una fina capa de vida,
compleja y posible, maravillosa y frágil.
De repente, nosotros los humanos, una especie surgida hace poco,
no se adhiere más a los controles inherentes a la naturaleza,
ha crecido en población, tecnología e inteligencia
hasta una posición de terrible poder. Ahora, nosotros manejamos el pincel."
Estamos al mando. Es terrorífico.
Yo pinto un cuadro cada 20 o 25 años. Este es el último,
(Risas)
y muestra la Tierra en, una especie de bandera del tiempo, a la derecha
trilobites, dinosaurios, etc.
y por el triángulo, llegamos a la civilización, y televisión,
atascos de tráfico, etc.
No tengo ni idea de qué vendrá después,
así que simplemente he usado cucarachas robóticas como el futuro,
como una especie de pequeña advertencia,
y dos semanas después de que este dibujo estuviese hecho,
recibimos, en realidad, nuestro primer proyecto, contrato, en AeroVironment,
sobre cucarachas robóticas, lo que me aterrorizó.
(Risas)
(Crujidos de papel)
Bueno, esas son todas las diapositivas que vamos --
Con el paso del tiempo, paramos nuestros programas ambientales
nos centramos, más, en los problemas energéticos realmente serios
del futuro, y creamos productos para la compañía,
y desarrollamos el coche de pruebas que General Motors fabricó,
el EV1, de --
e hicimos que la junta de Recursos del Aire aprobase las regulaciones
que estimularon los coches eléctricos, pero desde entonces se han disuelto,
y hemos hecho un montón de cosas, pequeños aviones autónomos y demás.
Tengo un Helios -- Veamos el primer vídeo --
Narrador: Con una envergadura de 247 pies, es mayor que un Boeing 747.
(Música)
La atención de sus diseñadores al detalle y su construcción,
le dan a la estructura de Helios la flexibilidad y fuerza
para tratar las turbulencias encontradas en la atmósfera.
Esto le permite atravesar las corrientes de aire
como si estuviese deslizándose sobre las olas del mar.
MacCready: Creemos que los extremos de las alas pueden tocarse en la parte superior sin quebrarse.
(Risas)
Narrador: Y Helios comienza ahora la maniobra para poner su lomo en dirección al sol,
para maximizar la potencia suministrada por sus paneles solares.
(Música)
Conforme el cielo se va oscureciendo, y la temperatura del aire exterior cae
por debajo de 100 grados bajo cero Fahrenheit,
el segmento ambientalmente más hostil del viaje de Helios
ha pasado sin ser advertido,
excepto por haber sido registrado por los sistemas de recogida de datos especialmente diseñados,
y sus sensores asociados.
Aproximándose a una altura de radar máxima de 96.863 pies,
a las 16:12 horas, Helios se encuentra por encima del 98% de la atmósfera terrestre.
Esto es 10.000 pies más alto
que el anterior récord del mundo de altitud, establecido por el SR-71 Blackbird.
(Aplausos)
PM: Ese avión tiene muchos usos, pero está diseñado para comunicaciones,
y puede volar tan lentamente que simplemente se mantiene a 65.000 pies,
finalmente será capaz de mantenerse en el aire todo el día, la noche, día, noche...
durante seis meses sin pausa, actuando como un satélite geostático,
pero a sólo diez millas sobre la Tierra.
Vamos a ver el siguiente vídeo, que muestra el otro extremo del espectro.
Narrador: Un minúsculo avión, el AV Pointer, se utiliza para vigilancia,
a efectos prácticos, un par de gafas errantes,
un ejemplo de alta tecnología de a qué nos puede llevar la miniaturización
si el operador se encuentra a distancia del vehículo.
Puede ser transportado, montado y lanzado a mano.
Alimentado por baterías, es silencioso y difícil de detectar.
Envía imágenes de vídeo de alta resolución al operador.
Con su GPS integrado, puede guiarse autónomamente,
y es lo suficientemente resistente como para aterrizar por sí mismo sin daños.
PM: De acuerdo, vamos a ver el siguiente --
(Aplausos)
Ese avión es ampliamente utilizado por los militares, actualmente, en todas sus operaciones.
Veamos el siguiente vídeo.
(Música)
Alan Alda: ya lo tiene, ya lo tiene, ya lo tiene, lo tiene en su cabeza.
Vamos a terminar nuestra visita con el circo volador de Paul MacCready
conociendo a su hijo, Tyler, quien, con sus dos hermanos,
ayudó a construir el "Gossamer Condor" hace 25 años.
Tyler MacCready: Puedes perseguirlo, de este modo, durante horas.
AA: Cuando se aburrieron del proyecto de su padre,
inventaron un extraordinario avión ellos solos.
TM: Y puedo controlarlo dándole impulso en un lado del ala, o en el otro.
AA: Lo llamaron "Walk-Along Glider".
(Música)
nunca he visto nada como esto.
¿Qué edad tenías cuando lo inventaste?
TM: Oh, 10, 11 -- (AA: Dios mío)
TM: 12, o así. (AA: Es increíble.)
PM: Y Tyler está aquí para mostrarles el "Walk-Along".
(Aplausos)
TM: Bien. Todos tenéis un par de ellos en vuestras bolsas de regalo,
y una de las primeras cosas --
la versión de producción parecía ir un poco a la deriva,
por lo que os sugiero doblar las puntas un poco hacia arriba
antes de intentar hacerlo volar.
Os haré una demostración de cómo funciona,
la idea es que planee sobre el empuje de vuestro cuerpo, como una gaviota planeando sobre un acantilado.
Conforme el viento viene, tiene que pasar por encima del acantilado, así que
mientras andas por el aire, va alrededor de tu cuerpo, y algo tiene que pasar sobre ti.
Por eso basta con mantener el planeador posicionado en esa corriente ascendente.
El lanzamiento es la parte difícil, tienes que mantenerlo bien alto, sobre tu cabeza,
empezar a andar hacia adelante, simplemente soltarlo, y puedes controlarlo de este modo.
(Risas)
Y además, como dije en el vídeo,
puedes hacerlo girar a izquierda o derecha,
con sólo poner el empuje bajo una u otra ala,
así puedo hacerlo -- huy, eso iba a ser un giro a la derecha.
(Risas)
Bien, esto será un giro a la izquierda.
Así, pero...
(Aplausos)
de todos modos --
Y eso es todo, así puedes controlarlo, hacia donde quieras,
da horas de diversión, y ya no se encuentran en producción,
así que tenéis auténticos artículos de coleccionista.
(Risas)
Y bueno, simplemente queríamos enseñaros un --
si podemos hacer funcionar el vídeo, eso es,
sólo un ejemplo de vídeo -- un pequeño vídeo de vigilancia.
(Risas)
Esto estaba volando por la fiesta de anoche, y --
y podéis ver cómo, sin más, puede volar por aquí,
y puedes espiar a quien quieras.
(Risas)
Y eso es todo, Iba a traer un avión,
pero me preocupaba darle a alguien,
así que pensé que esto sería un poco más suave.
Y esto es todo, sí, unos cuantos inventos.
(Aplausos)
De acuerdo.